now go to our coverage of the
coronavirus cases of the omicron variant
of covet 19 they are spreading in clark
county now this is a look at how the
current spike we're dealing with
compares to other spikes during the
pandemic that is back to april of 2020
this is the spike over the summer and
you can see the spike that is happening
right now so far the number of cases is
climbing rapidly especially over this
holiday weekend now let's take a look at
a different number this is the number of
hospitalizations also starting to go up
you can see the different peaks we've
had here this is this peak that's
happening right now the most serious
cases though not seeing the same spikes
we're talking about the number of people
in an icu right now and you can see or
on a ventilator by the way you can track
these numbers through the various peaks
we've had through the pandemic dating
back to again earlier in 2020
this is where we are right now the
number has not seen as much of an
increase throughout the process so far
the number of deaths also has not
started to go up as much as it has been
earlier in the pandemic you can see it
is down here but it is important to know
this number lags behind cases usually by
a few weeks that is a lagging indicator